e aí vocês vão começar a vir aqui dar um
aviso de começar o vídeo eu queria dizer
que vou estar em barueri sao paulo dia
21 onde a música campinas são paulo dia
29 em são paulo capital no dia 29 também
no dia 30 vou estar em vinhedo são paulo
a comprar ingresso para qualquer um
desses shows é só entrar no meu site que
é isso aqui tá aparecendo na tela até a
data em que vai comprar ingresso e aí
qualquer pessoa no meu show tem 10 de
desconto na cama com o primeiro tipo de
pipoca que eu queria saber quem foi o
gênio e teve a idéia de comer pipoca no
cinema
o rap para cabelos treinar atrapalha
assistir o filme importante do filme eu
sou o senhor das cavernas mortais o
homem imortal do mundo e vou contar
agora o meu plano maligno para dominar o
mundo
ah ah ah ah cara do meu lado como pipoca
com o cara vai votar o plano mali eo
plano é uma alegria para dominar o mundo
é o 188 descoberta andamento com essas
chuvas
sabia-se fama alegria e da tia me dera o
quadrinho e eu também mas toca aqui de 7
provocou o de ensino daquele povo que
vai ao ar no celular só que ele não
tenha a noção de baixar o brilho antes
de entrar no cinema a instalar tudo
escuro aquela coisa gostosa
é bom a pessoa olha desbloqueios eu a
minha mãe candê a cara de quem está
perto hope morre na mesma hora parece
que o dia amanheceu parece colocar o
tacuara dormir amanhã pra perguntar
alguma coisa negros na que liga paraná
estou perdendo a vista é o décimo quarto
tipo de pessoa que me incomoda muito
cinema mijão mijão sertão mijão mijão
seguinte ele sabe que a bexiga não
suporta um copo d'água e leva três
lavrinha vieram fica bebendo e saber que
eu to davi já dá aí vai dar 5 minutos
gostoso aviocar volta e os conversador
bicho lugar escala enfia modelo coração
até como direita que no fim está com a
mão esquerda não está fazendo jus ao que
foi feito não deixou qualquer verdade
car bicho ou é verdade mas tirador de
gafanhoto no cinema mãe tem que falar
baixinho bilhões que a china aperta não
só da amizade um bicho tão pouco esse
jogo 88 vontade de carga mija bem aqui
no meu pé não passar fome mas não é o
filme aí o filme é maior de 18 anos a
pessoa leva uma criança de colo a meia
hora de ser uma criança que é perfeito
assim completar é o fundão é a função
deles é bagunça o assunto que está sendo
dos cinemas são as oito pessoas que vão
com um único intuito rio aqueles no itaú
o filme entre eles catar que assistindo
filme de drama com o vôo eu nunca pensei
que eu teria câncer de pele e na
próstata o jack mais
você vai sair dessa
penso que não
meu filme conversado lá prédio já neste
livro já nesse livro ainda é muito bom e
tem 11 um reduto é verdade já li zhi
mastigador cabeça lá eu já falei que eu
não posso atender de do cinema mas
viajam e da sony sem saber que são paulo
- buemi já crê
[Música]
sozinho agora está acontecendo aqui que
me deixa feliz na hora que eu vou no
cinema eu vou comprar um ingresso que é
exatamente esse o país que elas acham
que a representá las cada junta na moeda
do copo assistir um filme ninguém vai
querer o quererem entrar inteiro 6
inteira normal 3d e 3d de barueri e são
paulo campinas são paulo são paulo
capital não se esqueça de clicar no
primeiro link na descrição do vídeo para
comprar ingresso do show eu quero que
você comente aqui embaixo qual foi a
pior coisa que já aconteceu quando você
foi no cinema e é claro se tiver postado
o vídeo clique aqui embaixo gostei é
muito importante que você volte lá no
facebook eu postei vídeo novo não sei
quem é e cinema e clique em curtir
demais seus amigos que gosta de cinema
você não perder ouvido quando é só ficar
inscrever-se toda vez que miley está
'muito obrigado' dez dias e até aqui é
nóis palermo